millions of people in europe also
continue to experience an extreme heat
wave sparking wildfires there it's
caused thousands of deaths that's right
chief meteorologist ted florando is
standing by in the weather center with
more as the temperatures soar to as much
as 30 degrees above normal right yeah
guys have big problems there of course
in europe wildfires in europe are
happening in multiple countries across
thousands of miles 10 rare wildfires
burning across london and the london
fire brigade is seeing its busiest day
since world war ii the same day the
country shattered the record for its
hottest day in known history that's 104
degrees they've never had that
temperature ever
this is it right this is uh the climate
change that we've been promised by
scientists can we still call the united
kingdom a cold country absolutely not
this level of extreme weather is
life-threatening and we really want to
make sure that people are not under any
illusion that this is serious and this
is here to stay for the foreseeable
future
western europe is still battling major
blazes that ignited last week in greece
police ran to doors shouting at
residents to flee just north of anthon's
french firefighters are in their ninth
straight day battling blazes twice the
size
of paris wow the problems we're dealing
with in europe and this is the graphic i
wanted to put together for you remember
the homes here if you've ever been out
there in europe the homes are not built
for heat they're built to trap in the
cold because it's mainly cold out there
obviously the people there also not used
to the heat here we are in the desert
we've been acclimated to it they have
not and that heat wave still continues
out there across the u.s look at these
numbers here 90s all the way in portland
109 here 100 degree temperatures in
dallas 90s across the central plains
states and this extends all the way to
the eastern seaboard boston 83 95 in new
york they're sweltering in dc out here
they have the humidity out here they
have the humidity and on top of that
that oppressive heat currently 109
degrees back to your home our humidity
is not quite as high but this still can
be very dangerous especially if you work
outdoors temperatures of course are
above normal for this time of year
excessive heat warnings start tomorrow
that does include las vegas that's at 11
am all the way until friday at night
until 8 pm and even the mountains these
are heat advisories so if you plan to go
to the mountains to cool off it's still
going to be in the 90s in some areas up
there we'll have more on your forecast
coming up